kuva batake h good,
what do we do now let's stick with
D6 that has proven itself Jae
okay so white plays a queen
pawn game
Torre
system yes
try with early activity
here so good now we have the
double pawn but that's not a
big deal with the a line  and so on
you have certain
options. I'm now wondering if
it somehow plays a role that I do
n't have the knight out yet.
Maybe you can take advantage of that in some way, for example
with F5 at
some
point. I don't know if that
's an idea  You can
definitely do it again, kick it once
and see where it goes, well
F5, that's a
move,
let's do it, but that looks dangerous,
a knight
C4, well, if White just keeps
moving around passively, then it'll prove
its worth  Somehow,
but the question is if he does
n't do that,
okay, yes,
somehow he wants to put it here, he does
n't want to put anything here,
strangely enough, let's
get out of the binding,
I'll prevent Springer C4, that's
too sensitive for me if he does
sometimes
makes an interesting
move puts the bishop in a very
strange position
but maybe wants to play with D5 you
jam if he plays D5 then B4 then
I no longer have a field with the nag
h well it's looking very
stupid now, take it
out of there like that
yes, I find that funny, people
who never do any active breeding and then
suddenly they come rolling in with all
hands, yes, okay, I have to
go back h
surprisingly now I could
play knight E4
e.g. well, I can still
and D with the knight  hit no, what does
it actually look good for the MPZ
so the pawn is weak now h there
's also another check here
but also just one check
probably
good I could also
hit there if he gets the square that would be
unpleasant I'll just go
back and have to go straight away  let's
get a little steam on the
clock, I'm not going to completely
sleep away again, yes then I'll take it away
A4 h can still do it,
actually maybe I do
n't understand anything at all, but it all looks
strange, so now he wants to go to C6 or
somewhere
like that
The whole story is slowly becoming clear
here. I just have a mer who is
still weak on C4 and he has a
terrible H2 here, that's terrible. The
bishop doesn't do anything and he wo
n't do anything in the game either. He
probably knows completely about
Granit
F2  It's also a
weakness so make a small reinforcement move
because the knight can't
move anymore. My good H4 was also a
shitty square but let's see
what he's doing now because there's
not much that you can move here
and oh  So even
rook G8 once threatened, yes,
I'm still interested in what he's playing on rook G8 now,
can't go to H2 or something like that, G3
just hangs like that, you can't put mate
anyway,
no, well then we'll take the path of another
pawn and  H3 also hangs
like that, rook H2
checkmated would be nice if you
could manage that, well
no move to be seen white resign yes that
also works with 30
seconds yes he simply
refused to play actively and then all that did
was blow up the entire queenside
blown up in between such an
opening there certainly wasn't much
going on F5 was risky I think I could
definitely have played knight C4 or something
difficult